[Music]
oMG I love this band
yeah I've been listening to him for 17
years got all their albums in cassette
and vine well I got my vinyl signed at a
pop-up shop in Chinatown
I caught him at the mammal exhibit a
while back a mammal exhibit would it
feel like a new venue no no at the
Natural History Museum Super Show Oh
she'll chill want to grab a PBR I could
just die right now she is my god it held
me about it I followed her on Instagram
snapchat Facebook and LinkedIn I don't
even care that cost $400 for a ticket I
totally quit my job just so I could have
enough time to buy these tickets online
before they sold out when you love you
person with only one name man this is my
jam for sure
wrap master Jeffries to go but he isn't
better than jay-z for sure but maybe
better than Kanye look better than Kanye
yeah
I'd pick him over Kanye maybe even over
Kendrick
I love how the mandolin and the wind
chimes just speak to my sister or so is
beautiful your soul is beautiful we
should stop talking we don't want our
voices to overpower music you're right
let's just sway
oh my gosh I love this song tell me
about it she looked good in her camera
wedding dresses a class you got that
right but it's not as good as that other
songs which one is that I know the one
about the girl in the pickup truck I
love her more than my pickup truck no no
the other one I knew she was alone when
she pulled up in a red Ram 2500 that's
the one in then that my wee girl
her brain is busted no no no I've been
better
I feel like I've got a good bruises
that's pretty good but as mosh pit
really a mosh pit if you don't get your
nose broken you remember to pay it back
at the dirty cellar awesome mosh pit I
got hit in the head with like four of
your body's punched in the face kicked
in the groin and I got mosh pit
[Music]
[Applause]